but we begin this morning with dangerous
and deadly weather for millions of
Americans this holiday weekend powerful
storms producing heavy rain and damaging
winds are taking aim at the eastern half
of the country from Texas to
Pennsylvania a tornado was confirmed
near Reston Virginia last night
thousands are without power this morning
as several towns try to recover from
days of devastating weather in
south-central Pennsylvania a building
partially collapsed last night in
Franklin County after severe winds and a
possible tornado struck there's no
immediate word on injuries Kenneth Craig
is at Newark Liberty Airport in New
Jersey where more than 200 flights were
cancelled or delayed on the start of
this holiday weekend Kenneth good
morning well good morning to you Anthony
I can tell you there are a lot of
frustrated passengers out here this
morning as you could imagine including
these folks behind me who told me they
were headed to Florida until their
flight was canceled just this morning
more than 1700 flights nationwide were
cancelled yesterday and now many of
those passengers are scrambling to find
alternatives on a busy holiday weekend
residents in Reston Virginia are
cleaning up this morning after a tornado
touched down last night causing a tree
to fall through the roof of a home
luckily no one was hurt this really does
look tornadic damage to me
Steve Xue Burke is a weather
investigator for the National Weather
Service he was on the ground after the
tornado hit I would say we're probably
in the 70 to 80 mile an hour range
shekinah Johnson of winston-salem North
Carolina was running errands when she
received a call saying a tree fell on
her apartment tree limbs sliced through
the roof of the building
forcing seven people to find a new home
for the night first question was was
everybody safe and all right but lucky
the kids wasn't there because of the
holiday rescue crews fanned out in Black
Mountain after the city experienced
heavy rain throughout the day severe
weather is bringing misery to the south
for these second weekend in a row oh
gosh tornadoes high winds and pounding
rains are destroying homes and leaving
some communities without power the storm
system is being blamed for at least five
deaths since
Thursday including an 8 year old girl
who was killed when a tree fell on a
Florida home Friday morning but a woman
in Morton Mississippi managed to survive
even as a twister destroyed her home
this house behind us is totally
destroyed with the exception of that
closet that she was in in
israeli-american the good news in all of
this is that many of the flight delays
and cancellations we were seeing just
last night have died down significantly
but the day is young and most of the
northeast dana is under a flash flood
warning so we are certainly not in the
clear yet yeah and a holiday weekend to
add to that kind of thank you we
appreciate it